hello everyone and welcome to the
genetics and genomics virtual event my
name is Fiona Scola
I'm the chief scientific officer at
Pacific Biosciences and I will be
presenting on highly accurate long
sequence reads or comprehensive genomic
analysis please
free to submit questions during my
presentation and I will follow up with
you by email my presentation will cover
two topics today at first I will
introduce highly-accurate long sequence
tree that are uniquely enabled by the
pectoral sequencing technology and then
I will talk about the new sequel to
system that we just launched weeks ago
for those of you who are not familiar
single-molecule real-time or smart
sequencing is based on the ability to
detect single polymerase molecules as
they synthesize DNA and read off the
bases that are being incorporated into a
growing DNA chain and this is detected
on the sequel instrument previously the
sequel one and now the sequel to
instrument that I will be talking about
in a little bit and with regard to the
sequence performance like bio is
characterized by very long reads high
consensus accuracy and minimal GC
percent and sequence complexity bias and
this slide just shows that for large
inserts greater than 20,000 bases or so
which we call continuous long reads on
CLR with the latest sequel system
chemistry version six release we have
increased all of those performance
parameters I will not go into those in
detail because that's not the focus of
today's talk and you can look at our
website at Peck be calm for more
information this is because I would like
to focus today's presentation on
circular consensus sequencing or CCS
which is a unique way of doing long
fragment and sort sequencing for
intermediate sized fragments up to about
20,000 bases the template molecule that
is used utilized inspect our sequencing
undergoes a procedure whereby we like a
Tampin adapters which makes the molecule
topologically circular and as you can
see here in this cartoon the polymerase
will then sequence this so-called smart
they'll open up the structure and
generate multiple sub reefs from this
particular DNA molecule both from the
forward strands and purple and
reverse trend in yellow excuse me
so with this technology is possible to
sequence the same base of the same DNA
molecule multiple times and then you can
take these sub reads that may have
random errors which are designated with
the red dots here and build consensus
from those sub reads to arrive at a very
highly accurate bone read so you can see
in this example distribution on the
right which shows the read length on the
x-axis and the density of data bases in
the particular read length areas that
we've completely shift at the
distribution so that most of the data
are now in very very long reads and so
these are the raw reads are
characterized by an average overall
throughput of up to 50 Giga bases of
polymerase reads the average read length
is in this particular example 84,000
bases half of the data are contained and
reads that are greater than 167,000
bases and on the sequel one system you
get about half a million reads now I
said that we're going around in circles
with the cartoon so how many passes do
you need to get a highly accurate long
read enough that many small houses for
220 or 99% read accuracy and 10 passes
for Q 30 or 99.99% accuracy and so what
you then end up with in the end as your
TCS reach high quality greater than 99%
accurate reads is depending on the
insert size between 150,000 to 500,000
read so in this example on the right for
a 9.8 average kilobase average insert
size 290 thousand CCS reads for a total
effective yields of 2.8 for Giga bases
of highly accurate phone reads and as
before as with clr the GC percent and
sequence complexity biases minimal which
is a hallmark of tech buyers who could
sing so this really changes and as a new
dimension to
sequencing applications as you know we
lived in an environment where we had
these two worlds until now where there
were short accurate reads and long noisy
reach have had a lot more error so in
this analogy Steph Curry here in
basketball you will always make it layup
100% of the time
and he still pretty good from
three-point range first on what I would
like to describe is the new capabilities
a third world as it was as it were when
you have very long accurate CCS reads so
the analogy would be that Steph Curry
makes the three-point choice shot 99.9%
of the time and there are many
applications where this new paradigm can
be applied the first one is shown here
in the area of targeted sequencing this
is a slide that was presented by Stuart
Scott who was at Point Sinai in
Singapore at the last American Society
for Human Genetics meeting and this talk
is also recorded and you see the link on
the bottom of the slide and he's
interested in among others
pharmacogenomics genes and what is shown
here is an 11,000 base segment of a
pharmacogenomics gene that he sequence
with on the peg box equal system and on
the top you can see the pink and blue
rows each row each of these lines will
present a full-length high quality C CSV
and you can see that there can they can
be segregated into two blocks
representing the two alleles the
maternal copy and the paternal copy and
you can see the quality of those reads
their full-length gene sequencing and
how the variants which are the vertical
lines see the heterozygous or homozygous
snips and in those buffets are connected
with regard to the two alleles this is
not just true for substitutions here I'm
zooming in to an insertion that's 25
bases and you can see how clean the data
is and not just substitution are
detected but also email the second area
that I would like to highlight for the
utility of cts-v is metagenomics to
example this is the first one in
targeted metagenomics or full-length 16s
ribosomal RNA gene sequencing there is a
recent preprint from a collaboration
that that we have with my Doherty and
other researchers showing that it is not
possible to completely resolve the 16s
rRNA gene at full length with high
quality using a ccs read and what the
paper describes is that it's not
possible to identify the multiple copy
that bacteria tend to have of the 16s
gene so previously as you see in the
crossed out of the right cartoon only
one 16s sequence is identified and put
into the database but of course many
bacteria have multiple copies and they
can different in their sequence and so
here for this step aureus example there
are three copies that have identical
sequence in yellow and then three
additional copies that each have a
unique sequence and the paper describes
that this can now be completely resolved
with high accuracy and quality with the
papyrus ICI has capability and then in
the other area of metagenomics and
shotgun metagenomics it's not possible
to take a 210 kb fragments of DNA where
the extraction allows for such a high
quality and arrive at extremely highly
accurate reads with high throughput
because at this length scale oftentimes
open reading frames and sometimes en
biosynthetic pathways are contained on a
single molecule that a sequence no
assembly is required for gene discovery
and so it becomes very efficient to
discover new genes discover more
proteins of interest compared to
alternative technologies and then lastly
before I get to human genome sequencing
the utility of CCS reads is also very
high in the area of full length RNA
sequencing or item seek we now have the
version 3 of the ISO seek software and
workflow that discovers and then
recovers 20% more gene or smart cell as
a much better runtime and improved
stability and unified support for the
multiplexing my colleague Liz sang has
developed a tool called
I saw phase that take into account the
small differences once again between the
maternal and the paternal genes and can
cluster on the reads into the two
alleles and so you can see allele
specific differences in slicing patterns
in the abundance of gene expression and
then lastly a new application that is
coming out and is being utilized include
increasingly utilized is in the era of
single cell full-length RNA sequencing
single paisa see there was a paper a
little while ago by having till dinner a
few presentations at the recent AG BT
meeting if you're interested check out
our website on that but then finally I'd
like to spend the rest of the
presentation on describing the utility
of these high-quality long reads for
human genome leasing contingent or
assembly and if you're very interested
in this area I'd like to point your
attention to a lot more detail in this
recent preprint that was posted on the
bio archives where we collaborate us
with a large number of institutions and
leading by petitions in this area
they're listed here on the right side
and where it's certainly very grateful
for their time and collaboration with
them that we carried out in this project
so for this demonstration we use a what
is arguably the best characterized human
genome sample from the genome in the
bottle that's the HT 0 0 to sample and
the reason for this is that this is
arguably the human genome sample for
which variants are best known and
verified from the genome and the bottle
consortium so that we could compare our
data to what was known to the best
possible quality from the reference
materials so the first on and the paper
then describes sets of one of the
benefits of the high quality
pcs reaso hypothesis we call them is
that they can be more unambiguously
mapped to more of the genome so one of
the figures of the preprint account
describes that at the highest mapping
quality these hifiberry can be
up to about 3% more of the human genome
grch37 reference and a couple of
examples here because the reads are
still read quite long but also highly
accurate they map very easily too
repetitive region so in this ITB
screenshot on the top to see the pick by
Ruiz again mapping very uniquely and
very confidently and you can phase again
into the two alleles and here's another
example of improved mapping in reference
divergent region so in this very
colourful sector here the sequence of
this particular sample differs quite
markedly from the reference but because
the reads are long they sped through
this region and you can continously map
throughout this region and result this
region completed and then finally in the
area of the noble assembly we found that
the tech bio cts reads get more accurate
and more correct representations of the
final sequence and so the green curve
out lenses and I don't have time to
describe this graph in great detail but
you can see that compared to the tech
bio TLR and orange or other competing
technologies you get a much higher
representation of high quality sequence
on the order of q50 half of the genome
is q50 or greater and all of the genome
essentially is 240 or greater and that
compares favorably to previous
approaches so then finally I'd like to
go into this a little bit more detail
but in the context of introducing the
newest equal to system which as we said
we just launched formally and is now
available on please go to our website
and the link is down on the bottom to
check out the performance and the
characteristics of this equal to system
in a nutshell we have changed the smart
cell to an increased multiplex from 1
million to 8 million and so it is pretty
much a straight up increase in yield to
play about a factor of 8 which then
result in a reduced project time lower
cost while and it's an important of
course maintaining a
performance to the previous equal system
so here's an example of where the data
for CCS being overlaid in yellow you can
see the sequel system and then in blue
you see the sequel to system and you can
see that the distributions are
essentially identical but you just get a
lot more reads and also you can see that
we've actually improved them there's a
longer tail of very long polymer entries
in excess of 250 up to three hundred
kilobases in length so with a factor of
eight then the overall yields per smart
cell run is typically can exceed 300
gigabases that then is being translated
into a CCS yield of highly accurate long
reach of about 16 Giga bases and in
terms of accuracy
you see 99.8% that it's the average so
similar to before but in fact we have
even improved on the number of passes
that it takes for the sequel to system
recall that in the beginning of the
presentation I told you that it takes
ten passes for Q 30 or 99.9 percent
accuracy with the sequel to system on
the bottom you can see that it only
takes 8 passes so you get to consensus
faster and so more leads will fall into
that filter setting before the we launch
the system formally two weeks ago we
have an early access program where we
place the signal to system at five
selected customer sites and ask the
researchers to run both control and real
examples using a pre-release chemistry
version and this got off to a very good
start this is Jeremy schmutz from
HudsonAlpha
presenting on the very first smart
selling sequel to system that would ever
run outside of the PEC file laboratories
and he got 63 Giga bases of theta this
was a sorghum sample that's he then used
for a de novo assembly a high quality
the noble assembly of about 720 mega
bases and the contiguity the conjugate
50
11.9 megabases was over an order of
magnitude about an order of magnitude
larger than what he has compared to his
current reference and it was also highly
accurate with less than one in 10,000
basic error overall he are the
controller the results from the entire
early access program 120 smart cells
were run only three run failures so the
system is very stable and reliable and
both control and user samples will run
actually 80% of the samples of this
program we're real-world samples that
the researchers were interested in and
then on the left you see the CLR results
51 smart cells the average yield with 75
gigabases which is exactly pretty much
eight folds compared to what the
researchers get right now with the
sequel one system over the global
install base and the average feed link
for some of 20 kilobases and on the
right with the CPS mode sixty six months
over run the average yields with 300
Giga bases then that's about effect of
12 and that's largely because longer
movie times are available in the sequel
to system resulting in average CCS
fields of 18 Giga bases and average long
read length of 75 kilobases
so then coming back and applying the new
hire crew point of the sequel to system
to the genome in the bottle sample I'd
like to show you some of the newer data
that are not part of the preprint
because they were run on the sequel to
system so with regard to structuring and
calling those are genetic variants
defined as greater than 50 bases inside
the overview is that you can now use the
new version of the smart analysis
software to run both the mapping and
then the structural variant calling
using our pdsd structure variant color
and as a result you get a VCF file that
gives you the structure variance this
works very well as you know pet i/o is a
very comprehensive
provides a comprehensive view of
structure variance and that is also the
case of course for the sequel to system
but with much higher throughput
lowering the cost and the time for these
types of project and you can see on the
right very excellent recall and
precision relative to the genome in the
bottle truth sets here are some examples
this is a heterozygous allo deletion in
issue zero zero one actually you can see
on the bottom 319 in one of the alleles
with the bottom allele whether it has
the number 319 and you can see how clean
the data are each read showing precisely
the right insertion it's the right
Silesian size and all the snips that are
neighbouring for the particular deletion
and they're all phase as well here's the
homozygous line deletion that were the
there's a gap there but garite's are
spanning this gap completely high
confidence detection of the deletion and
this is what is an inversion looks like
in the a PP intronic region while you
have these breaks and the color
inversion from pink to blue and and and
back with regard to small variant
calling this is now much improved with
the hi-fi capability and you can
initially use the GAC Quique Apple type
color that's been used extensively for
single nucleotide variation calling and
you can see that on the right in this
table that for single nucleotide
variants precision and recall is it's
quite respectable but for IND else is
not quite good only in the 80s of
percent and so the haplotype color gatk
expects a narrow mode of short reads
which is characterized by high mismatch
error and the low in Valero however with
the Peck bio-data it's actually quite
the opposite there is a higher in
Delaware or as much lower mismatch error
so we collaborated with pool and the de
variant caller team to adapt pipelines
for the unique characteristics of the pi
PI OPC data and you can see that with
the new data type specific model with
deep variant learning the error model of
the
I reach from training data we can now in
the table on the right to an excellent
job of open CMD precision and recall as
well as in dell precision and recall i
sort of improve detection and
sensitivity for both snv's and endo and
then of course the long reach the long
range information can be used to face
the small phase the small variance you
can use whatsapp for that and you can
see on the table again on the right that
there's substantial face blocks the
three smart cell theta M on HT 0 0 2 and
so you get both small variant calls and
it automatically provides long range
phasing information I should note
however that of course the Facebook size
is driven by the heterozygosity and the
insert length so of the type of sample
human versus plant animal and also the
type of library that you're making and
so these data then in summary are highly
concordant in the high confidence region
from the human the bottle and here's an
example shown where the top is the
genome on the bottom proof and then
below that is the deep variance test so
you can see they're very concordant but
in addition there are many regions for
example duplicated regions or regions
that have solutions where you can see
there is a gap there's a blank space for
the genome in the bottle truth and the
deep variant provides this data because
of the longer highly accurate spec bio
reads so then you may ask what kind of
coverage do I need for doing these types
of experiments and this is analyzed in
the preprint and what we see really that
for SMBs on the left in build with the
variants you can see that at about 15
full coverage both precision and recall
has largely saturated and fortuitously
that is also the case with structure
variance which is shown here and with
regard to the Nobel assembly so here it
is all put on the on one slide and you
can see that 15 fold high fidelity
coverage which is about two to three
smart cells depending on
quality of the library two to three
smart self a.m. in our recommendation
provides the best current trade-off
between the cost and the results there
are example datasets available on the
from sequel to system if you are
interested in looking at this yourself
and analyzing the data
there are several human examples that
are all listed here and I won't go into
that but h20 one two and five that are
publicly available and exploded data so
in summary this new data type allows you
to with these tectonic - reads it allows
you to accurately call small variants
and structure brands over 90% of human
genome and 50 full coverage with say 11
Kenyans which provides a good trade-off
between cost and results so with that I
will stop but not before I would like to
thank the entire scientific community
they continue to invest in applying the
tech biotechnology and we are very
grateful for their time and efforts and
for the collaborations and working
together with them that have by now
resulted in well over 5,000 publications
about five newspapers per day in all
different areas of science and I am very
excited to see what will be possible now
in this new third world of having highly
accurate long reads on opening these new
application spaces that I mentioned and
then lastly I'd like to point out a new
smart grant program which closes on May
17 and if you're interested you can
actually win some free sequencing on
this equal to on the new sequel to
system this particular smart grant we
have many throughout the year but this
particular one is in the area of human
transcriptome research so if you want to
do some ICC studies and leverage the
higher throughput of the sequel to
system you can go to Peck be calm slash
mark grant and enter your proposal there
and then lastly I'm excited that we will
have a web
are on June 5th at 9:00 a.m. Pacific
time where three of the three
researchers who were part of the early
access program for the sequel to system
will be describing their experiences and
their results generated with the sequel
to system providing around eight times
more data even more highly accurate long
reads and resulting in reduced project
times for faster results so if you're
interested in hearing them speak about
their experiences please go and register
at Peck be calm less human and with that
I would like to thank you for your
attention I look forward to your
questions and thank you very much and
goodbye